Jag gillar också att lyssna fram leverantörer.
Jag tycker det är så pinsamt med många som gör speditörer.
Det är ju lite sak att bara prissa på kunderna egentligen.
Agera som bluffbolag.
Och det är du är färdigt gärna fram i ljuset.
Men är det så, nu gick vi in, du ska få berätta lite om dig själv, men jag bara hoppar in här lite.
Det är rätt sjukt att ni, vad sa du, omsökt en 160 miljoner.
Jag är ju Chernobyl-generationen, jag kan inte ta...
Du vet, vem är du typ?
Det låter inte så jävla verkligt.
Du har rendesbra ord.
Ni har inga syra kolleger, ni bråkar aldrig, och det finns inga tunga ögonblick.
Nu kanske jag får skit för detta, men...
Jag håller med.
Men, vad brinner ni mest för?
Då välkomnar vi Björn på BGA Group till podden Make Sweden Strong.
Tjena Björn.
Tjena, kul att få ha med.
Ja, jäkligt kul att ha dig här faktiskt.
Jag tänker att för alla oldschool e-handlare så vet de ju nog vem du är, men med tanke på er omsättning och er tillväxttakt och liknande så måste ni ju vara en av de minst rapporterade e-handlarna som finns i Sverige jämfört med motsvarande e-handlare.
Ja, så är det väl och det känns så mycket av de här medierna.
Man vill hitta några rapporterare som kan köra väldigt flitigt på dem.
Så, ja, då tycker jag väl också det här.
Absolut, absolut.
Är det att du av misstag har lyckats be en journalist och piss off i någon intervju någon gång?
Nej, det är det inte.
Jag brukar vara väldigt fin med att se skådorna på ett bra sätt.
Jag tycker bara det är fascinerande för när man går in och kollar på BGA Groups och du är dessutom ganska transparent i saker du skriver och liknande.
Så det finns ju ganska mycket info att hitta där.
Och för er som inte känner till BGA Groups så kanske man ska säga att det är ramar.
Jag tror att det är ramar primärt, men även posters och speglar på nätet.
Ramar och posters som är det stora för oss, ska man säga, och sen speglar på det.
Yes.
Kan du inte ge oss en liten rundown om BGA Group?
Bara kort, hur det startade, hur mycket ni omsätter idag och vilka länder ni är kanske.
Ja, absolut.
Räckta upp allt annat länder blir ganska jobbigt.
Vi är mot 14 marknader idag och inom ett par dagar nu är det 10 till.
Så vi kör mot alla länder i EU kan man säga.
Plus Norge, Sverige och UK idag.
Och vi omsätter ungefär 350 miljoner i fjol.
I år räknar vi med 40 miljoner.
Det vi säljer som sagt är ramar, posters och speglar.
Vi har hållit på med e-handel i EU, det har blivit 12 år nu.
Och jag har drivit bolag i 19 år med BK.
Det är en lite sjuk...
Det känns som att det har verkligen accelererat på slutet eller att ni har gått internationellt på slutet.
Är det så?
Ja, internationellt absolut det stämmer.
Men vår tillväxtresa har varit ganska jämn under många år.
Det är bara att volymerna har ökat ju större man blir egentligen.
Men vi har alltid haft en tillväxtkurva som har gått uppåt om man säger så.
Det är bara att det blir en hockeyklubba.
Ju mer det blir om man säger så.
Sen har vi lättare avtagit lite mer också, men det är ju för att det är svårt att växa i den takt man tyckte var roligt för några år sedan.
Efter corona ökade man väldigt mycket där.
Sen har vi fortsatt att öka men det är inte alls på de behov om man tycker att det var roligt eller inte.
Vilken takt hade varit roligt?
Egentligen obegränsat.
Man tycker att man aldrig kommer att vara nöjd.
Hur mycket man har växt är alltid dåligt tycker jag.
Det är minsta avfattning av det hela.
Det verkar som en härlig inställning.
Du motiverar personalen till att...
Jag gissar att ni inte har några större styrelsemöten.
För du äger större delen av begre avrådet.
Jag äger större delen av bolaget, sen har vi en väldigt kompetent ledningsgrupp.
Det är väldigt mycket fokus på oss på logistiken och de delarna som bolag.
Sen är det jag och Emil Sjöström som är egentligen och E-handels-team som driver det framåt.
Så det är vi som tar alla strategiska beslut inom E-handel.
Hur vi ska driva tillväxt på det satta.
Men brukar du komma in där på månadsmötet och bara säga att det här var bra men jag är inte nöjd?
Ja vi har ju satt den budgeten att vi ska växa 25% som är realistiskt mot hur vi växer just nu.
Men det är ingenting man är nöjd med.
Det ska man ju såklart inte vara.
För det är ganska risigt tillväxt tycker jag.
Utan man vill ju mycket högre än det, definitivt.
Jag lämnar den diskussionen lite där så kan ju folk få meditera lite om hur det själv hade känts om de omsatte 350 miljoner och de växte med 25% och de kände missnöjligt bara att sitta igenom kroppen på grund av de siffrorna.
Jag tror att om man är nöjd så ska man nog lägga av.
Då ska man ta sig vidare egentligen.
Man ska hela tiden brinna för att göra det bättre.
Annars är man på fel ställe på det sättet.
Jag köper det.
Jag tror bara inte att alla har den inställningen men färgerna har full respekt för den inställningen.
Kan vi få en liten kort björnintro?
Vi ska inte fastna i vart du gick i skolan som tolvåring, men vem är du som person?
Jag började i förskola.
Men jag kommer från Gävle, jag har stivit i bolaget där under många år.
Och den sista åren har min familj flyttat upp till Vändalen.
Jag bor både i Gävle och Vändalen.
Men jag försöker spänna så mycket tid som möjligt upp i fjällen.
Jag gillar natur och den bitarna.
Och tycker även att det är superort att bygga bolag här uppe.
Så hela vår administrationssida med nya tjänster tillsätter vi här uppe.
Så vi har gått från 0 till 7 anställda upp till Vändalen på ett år.
Och det är det vi drar in i att bygga bolag i fjällvärlden helt enkelt.
Varför är det viktigt?
Nej det är en så härlig genuinsättning här uppe.
Och att det är väldigt lätt att hitta kompetent personal.
För det är många som vill sköta hit.
Det är ett väldigt attraktivt ställe att bo på.
Att kunna bo nära naturen.
Så det är väldigt lätt att hitta folk från hela Sverige som verkligen vill sköta hit.
Och att jag brinner för att utveckla byggen och bygden.
Och driver även vissa sidoprojekt.
Jag har köpt upp en paddelhall möjligen.
Och ska öppna en trampolinpark här också under ett år.
Så att jag brinner för att utveckla Vemdalen och Härjedalen kan man säga.
Jag tänkte att vi skulle komma dit lite senare, men vi kan hamna där lite direkt.
Hur många bor i Vemdalen?
700 bor fasta.
Så att bygga en paddelhall där och en trampolinpark där, hur funkar det egentligen?
Det är en av Sveriges största turistnästinationer.
Det är över 100 000 bäddar här.
Det finns helt fel.
Så det är väldigt mycket folk under säsong.
Antalet bor fasta är väldigt låt, men det är väldigt mycket folk i rörelse här.
Finns det en liten sektmentalitet bland er 700 OGs som bara tänker att nu kommer alla turister här, men ni vet vilka som bestämmer egentligen?
Det är extremt mycket inflyttning här i Dalarna också.
Av barnen som var i skolan är det väldigt många som är nyinflyttade.
Det är både som flyttar in och som flyttar ut.
Det är väldigt välkomnande till nya människor.
Utan turismen skulle det inte finnas någonting här.
Så resonerar jag i alla fall.
Det är det som är en levande by.
Annars skulle det bara vara en by på landet som skulle vara modekisk.
Det är sunt kul.
Jag fungerar lite likadant.
Jag hade gärna sett i framtiden att man fick inte såklart bygga sitt egna kvarter.
Det här är en ort där de flesta känner varandra och man tillsammans hjälper till och bygger upp en ort på det sättet som man vill ha den.
Det finns en gemenskap om man satsar tillsammans och liknande.
Det är beundransvärt.
Istället för att man drar till, jag vet inte alla verkar dra till Marbella eller något liknande, så åker de till Sverige på semester.
Ja men exakt.
Vi ska inte hamna i någon sorts romantisk bild av Smorter, utan nu ska vi prata lite BGA Group här.
För det är väl kanske ändå därför folk lyssnar på podden.
Du har ju en väldigt lång historia med BGA Group.
Det är som du sa, 19 år och 12 år i e-handel.
Finns det några ögonblick under den här resan som verkligen har varit avgörande?
Du får inte bara säga när vi blev en e-handel, utan det var det här som gjorde det bolaget ni är idag.
Nej, alltså allting handlar ju om små, små saker hela tiden.
Att liksom stå fast vid sin idé.
Egentligen våga testa och vara väldigt mycket marknadsvarig i alla bolagen.
Sedan var det ju såklart att corona har gjort så att e-handeln exploderade.
Det är väl corona-uppbrott som jag skulle säga att vi hanterade på bra sätt inom bolaget genom att snabbt expandera till nya marknader då.
Och hållet var tillräckligt starkt och jag var beredd på det.
Men var ni redan då i en internationell expansion och den bara snabbades på eller blev det snarare så att ni såg att nu kom corona, nu kör vi?
Vi var ut i Norden då och hade gjort ett mindre äventyr ut på tyska marknaden och före som vi lagde ner.
Då var vi inte redo på det sättet.
Men när corona kom så märkte vi att försäljningen snackade iväg och vi såg att den recessionen var ut i Europa.
Så då gjorde vi ett nytt försök och nu var vi mer redo som internation.
Det var lättare att sälja helt enkelt.
Det var det som utgick igång i nederländerna exempelvis.
Försäljningen var upp på 50% av svenska nivån inom en vecka eller två.
Så det gick extremt fort att etablera sig då.
Att kunderna skrek i att snubbarna handlade online i Europa.
Och skulle du uppleva att, för det verkar ju vara ett problem för europeiska bolag, att det är så många olika marknader jämfört med till exempel amerikanska företag som kan gå lite större, lite snabbare.
Men ser de olika marknaderna liknande ut i beteenden eller kan ni liksom ta lärdom av de olika eller blir det weird?
Jag vet inte men jag skulle säga att USA är så långt på flera marknader heller.
För ska vi köra hela USA då krävs det också att vi har flera lager uppsatt och det är väldigt kulturskillnader och många olika tidzoner bland annat.
Så jag skulle nog inte säga att USA är så mycket lättare på resa heller.
Sen har vi i Europa utmaningar med flera språk och de bitarna.
Men den utmaningen har ju blivit mindre ju mer AI och de bitarna kommer så att man lättare kan bli översätta på det sättet.
Okej, så ni gjorde en internationell expansion som snabbades på i coronatecken.
Finns det några andra?
För att ni måste ju ändå ha byggt upp en basorganisation som klarade av den expansionen.
Det kan ju inte bara ha varit att nu kom corona, vi gick internationellt.
Då hade ju jättemånga bolag gjort så.
Utan vad var det som fanns på plats?
Vad var det som gjorde att ni kunde expandera på det sättet?
Ja, men det är ju liksom som mitt borta är KBK, kör bara kör.
Man måste våga gasa och inte tänka efter så mycket.
Utan det är ju bara att lösa det resans gång.
Vi fick ju liksom, vissa gånger fick vi rekrytera 50 nya medarbetare på lagret för att hinna med under hög säsong.
Utan det var bara att köra och lösa problemen.
Det är bättre att få insallit och sen försöka lösa allt omkring.
Det upplever vi.
Det är det jag tycker många är för slör.
Jag vet ju att du har det motto, kör bara kör, men du har ju också pratat i vissa poddar och sånt där om att, du har fått, jag vet inte om man säger pantsätta sitt hus, men belåna sitt hus eller man har fått ligga ut med pengar.
Det har ju varit tuffa situationer och sånt där.
Absolut att du har löst detta och det har gått bra och du har ju liksom byggt ett fantastiskt bolag på grund av det.
Men risken är ju relativt stor och Ja men så är det ju bäst att vara utfärs.
Det finns ganska många där det inte hade gått...
Ja men skulle du ändå rekommendera det som en grundstrategi till folk, att det är det här man behöver göra?
Ja men alltså se på idrottsstjärnor och allting.
Ska du lyckas och bli bäst, eller duktig i alla fall, så måste du våga satsa.
Och det är ju samma inom företag också.
Kör du inte extremt mycket till mark, gå ner i lön, belånar, gör allt, då kommer du inte vinna heller.
Sen finns det vissa som lyckas ändå, riktiga geni relaterar på jättesmart affärsidé och sådana saker.
Men för de flesta så är det ju sten och arbetet som gäller.
Annars kommer du inte att lyckas som entreprenör.
Hur många tror du på riktigt har den?
För det faller ju bort ganska många människor i den som faktiskt kommer ta stryk och som kanske förlorar vissa delar av sina liv då eller liksom vad de hade hoppats på.
Hur många procent av befolkningen tror du faktiskt är beredda att göra den satsningen som krävs?
Ja, uppenbarligen inte så många.
För det är ju extrema riskrital och det ska man medvetna om också.
För mig var det ju många år som alla tillgångar stod på min samt.
Man kan det här som helst gå i person på kurs, när man satsar väldigt hårt och då får man leva fattigt sedan.
Men jag, för mig, tyckte det var risken.
Jag vill utveckla bolag, annars skulle jag tycka att det var mer att hålla på.
Så det är så, men inte sådana vagnar.
Men det är ju inte någonting för alla.
Men vill du lyckas så måste du våga.
Det är min inställning.
Hur har du hanterat den ekonomiska...
För jag kan uppleva, jag har ju lite liknande situation.
Vi har ju alltid haft stora likviditetsproblemer som vi säljer i gymutrustning, vi ligger ju alltid utom det.
Mycket pengar, det är en långsam bransch.
Och en av de tuffa situationerna är ju inte att hantera det vanliga jobbet, utan på något sätt vet man ju vad man ska göra.
Det tuffa kan ju bli när det är de här stora likviditetssvängningarna och man bara känner att fan, jag kan inte köpa lunch just nu för att jag har investerat detta i bolaget den här månaden.
Har du något sätt för att hantera det mentalt eller tänker du bara bort det?
Hur tänker du kring den situationen?
I många år hade jag väldigt ont i magen av likviditeten av de bitarna som har varit problem.
Sen har jag försökt att infalla mig själv senast i året.
Har jag hållit på nu i 19 år utan att det går åt helvete så har man bevisat att man vet vad man gör på det sättet.
Jag har försökt att släppa tankarna mer och mer på det sättet.
Men det är ju något som ligger i bakgrunden hela tiden.
Tankarna kommer väl någon gång i banan.
Man vet ju aldrig var man står om sex månader.
Det kan man skita i sig hela tiden.
Det är väl lite av tjusningen också med adrenalinet i bakgrunden.
Att man vet att man har öd till sina egna händer ändå.
Det är vad jag åstadkommer i min roll.
VD på BGA har ju väldigt stor påverkan.
Hur det går.
Jag tänker nu att du var rättamärmig om jag har fel.
Men jag tror att senaste året ni gjorde ett väldigt fint resultat också.
Ett ganska bra plusresultat.
Skulle du säga att du upplever att nu har du en affärsverksamhet där du kan driva den med ett visst plusresultat?
Eller tror du att ni inom det närmsta tiden ändå kommer hamna i de här stora svängningarna ändå?
Att behöva ta stora lån för att fortsätta växa?
Kommer du behöva hantera den här stressen de närmsta tio åren?
Eller har du hittat en affärsmodell nu?
Är du på den storleken att det funkar nu?
Tio år framöver har jag aldrig planerat, utan det är vuxet som går framåt mina planer går på det sättet.
Men just nu ligger vi väl stabilt, men det handlar också om hur mycket tillväxt vi vill driva.
Vi vill växa väldigt fort, så handlar det väldigt mycket om att bygga lager och bygga saker som binder likviditet.
Så det är alltid det där utmaninget hur fort vi vill växa jämfört med vilken risknivå man vill ta.
Och ju äldre man blir med familjer och de bitarna så blir man väldigt riskbenägen.
I alla fall har det varit så för mig.
Hur har ni gjort för att kunna fortsätta växa de här åren när det finns en enorm konkurrens inom kanske framförallt postervärlden, men även givetvis ramar och liknande med alla lågprisaktörer från Kina och liknande.
Eftersom ni är ett så diversifierat bolag i termer av marknader så har ni ju inte en jättestor hemma marknad där ni verkligen så här här sätter vi 100% på varumärken och liknande.
Vi jobbar ju ganska många marknader, lite som en liknande strategi som de här lågprisvarumärkena gör.
Hur bemöter man det där och varför fortsätter ni växa?
Jag tror väldigt mycket att både jag och min kollega Emil, som också delägare i bolaget, hela tiden tänker hur vi kan göra saker bättre.
Och hela tiden nördar ner oss inte inom vår bransch, för vår bransch känns väldigt spretig över så många marknader.
Men vi har en grundläggande idé hur vi tycker e-handeln ska fungera.
Och hur vi tycker det är viktigt till enkelhet, sekund och byggd assortiment.
Men ni är aldrig var nöjda.
Jag tror det är jätteviktigt.
Aldrig vara nöjd att våga driva på sin egen tes.
Vad man tycker funkar och inte funkar.
Magkänsla, som byggs upp på erfarenheten.
Men upplever du då att den magkänslan eller erfarenheten, är den bättre då än konkurrenterna eller gör ni något annat?
Eller är det för att du har varit i denna tillräckligt länge?
Nej men jag skulle väl säga att det är våran magkänsla, hur vi bygger bolaget som vi gör bättre än våra konkurrenter.
Att det är så är det det beror på.
Att vi är mer hungriga helt enkelt.
För det går ju inte att identifiera någonting tycker jag som man gör bättre än alla andra.
Det är att man är hungrig och hela tiden vågar fästa.
Det är väl våran styrka.
Man får aldrig vara nöjd.
Kan du ta med lite på vart dina ansvarsområden ligger i bolaget idag?
Ni är väl runt mitt i anställda Isaya.
När du säger det här med magkänsla, vilka delar är det som genomsyras av din och Emils magkänsla?
Vart är det ni tar de yttersta besluten dagligen?
Inte bara där ni står som ansvarig och sen skriver av ett papper, utan vart är det ni verkligen påverkar?
Man kan säga att det är det vi inte är med och påverkar, det är logistikdelen och kundtjänst.
Det mina ansvarsområden är, det är all marknadsföring, sköter jag.
Sen är jag inköpsansvarig och sköter inköp och prissättning och alla de vittarna.
Sen delar jag miljöavsvarig som e-commerce manager, vi bygger upp sajt och sådana saker.
Du har egentligen flera roller.
Hur länge kan du hålla på så innan du börjar ta korkade beslut?
Korkade beslut tar jag väl hela tiden.
Sen har jag många som assisterar mig som jag kan lägga ut specifika uppgifter på, det är så många marknader så om jag gör en förändring på ett ställe så kan jag risa någon annan miljö på fler ställen.
Men jag tror att den stora styrkan för oss är också att jag har hant om marknadsföringen, inköp, prissättning och de strategibitarna.
Och den tre grejerna görs eftersom jag kan ta väldigt stora och snabba beslut eftersom jag har en extrem helhetsbild av bolaget.
Och kan våga gasa och se effekterna väldigt fort.
På det jag gör och vad som inte funkar.
Jag köper det, ni behöver inte köra så mycket möten eller rapporter utan...
Och det är därför jag kan ha sån bra magkänsla och så att jag har sån stor insyn i hela bolaget.
Ja, men du säger det lite här själv nu också och det har ju...
Alltid när man nämner dig, när man pratar i e-hallens sammanhang så säger nästan alla man pratar med så säger de aha Björn, det är han som kör sin egen Google Ads-grej.
Det har lite blivit en grej att du gör det själv och att du inte har hyror.
Är det fortfarande så?
Det funkar, du säger ju marknadsföring, men är det du som sitter och pillar?
Det är det.
Jag köper det här, absolut det är bra att få översikten och sånt där, men är det den bästa användningen av tiden?
Jag kan inte säga någonting som är viktigare än försäljning i ett bolag som ska delas av tillväxt.
För mig är det att kriga in varje krona varje dag.
Det redan handlar om.
Varför gör inte alla så som du gör?
Det handlar väl också om intresse.
Jag har hållit på med Google Ads sedan det var Google Adburch och sedan redan butikkedja.
Jag har hållit på med det väldigt många år.
Och brinner för både, jag älskar fysisk försäljning och jag älskar försäljning online.
Jag älskar försäljning.
Jag ser mig själv som en säljare.
Och har nu hamnat i rollen som säljare online.
Och drivs hela tiden av det.
Hur fan kan jag få bättre tillväxt?
Vad kan jag smaka det?
Så jag sitter och följer med väldigt mycket nyheter där, och testar saker och klurar på de bitarna.
För att hela tiden tänka, hur kan vi öka sälj?
Sedan de här grejerna med nöjda kunder och sådana saker.
Det är liksom, det är hygieneffekter.
Det är ju hygien bara för mig, du ska ha supernöjda kunder.
Så ska det bara vara.
Sedan lyckas vi inte alltid sålt ut på alla matställda, men du ska ha nöjda kunder.
Jag köper det.
Jag tycker bara det är ett spännande resonemang, för det är extremt ovanligt att man som, ska man säga vd eller grundare eller ansvarig för ett större bolag, sitter med de detaljdetaljerna.
Det är ju verkligen ett petjobb på många sätt vis.
Och även att du sitter med inköp på det sättet, det måste ju vara en enorm mängd produkter ni sitter med inköp.
Sen har vi väl ett smarta system där, så att själva löpande inköp har hjälp, där det bara är efter en tabell, vi ska göra inköp.
Men alla container vi inköp, sköp vi själva, och sen vilka nya produkter vi ska ta in, sköp vi alla.
Priser, ingen experimenterare med priser.
Vi har hela dokumentens sammansättning att sitta med, och det tar en hel del tid.
Och sen priser vi med leverantörer.
Hur många nya produkter tar ni in på en vecka?
Det kommer i skåk, sen är det oftast av reserier om man säger så.
Så det är kanske inte...
Det är svårt att säga hur mycket nytta det är på en vecka.
Sen handlar det mycket om att erkänna besvinkliga produkter, med andra typer av produkter som kan få ner prisnivåer och sådana saker, och jaga kostnadsbiten.
För mig är det ju kostnaderna, det är ju där du vill få ner kostnadsmassan på det som inte verkts för kund.
Jag tycker bara det går...
Och jag tycker det roligaste som finns.
Det går ju igenom att...
Det är ju bra att du går igång för detta, det är ju tydligt.
Det är verkligen procent här och där som gäller.
Ja, så är det.
Ökar försäljningen, sänker kostnaderna kan jag trycka ännu mer så att man kan svara in, växa ännu mer.
Så när man då...
Vad är det, om det ska vara helt...
Inget så här fint svar eller inövat svar eller något sånt där utan om du är verkligen helt ärlig, vad är det du ska göra med bolaget?
Vad är det det går ut på?
Jag drivs av två saker.
Den nyaste drivkraften som vi har, det är ju faktiskt att skapa arbetsnivåer, bli en stor arbetsgivare och bidra till Härjedalen.
Det är en serie som är jätteviktig och rolig sak och över det brinner jag alldeles för just nu.
I övrigt så brinner jag för att bygga så stort bolag det bara går, omsättning och vinstmässigt.
Både för att kunna skapa nya sidoprojekter, men även för att se hur stort jag kan lyckas göra det här själv.
Alltså inte att jag driver det själv, vi har extremt mycket kompetenta medarbetare med mig, men hur stort kan jag stå som först på VGA och ge upp det här bolaget.
Det är någonting jag brinner jättemycket för.
Och se, hur mycket jag blir bäst på hela tiden.
Det är som en tävling för dig själv bara för att se vad...
Som ett sprintlopp, fast i bad och falla in.
Skulle du säga att den dagen, det är väl tråkigt men någon dag dör du liksom.
Bryr du dig om vad som händer?
Sen absolut att ni har gjort bygden och anställda, låt oss låtsas att alla de får jobb och får leva kvar, men har du någon nostalgi i bolaget eller har detta bara, är detta en utmaning för dig för att se vart du hamnar?
Jag har ju många kompisar och kollegor som har sålt bolaget och man inser ju vilken omställning det skulle vara om man inte drev bolag känner jag.
Så jag trivs väldigt bra där jag är just nu och kan driva bolag och sådana saker.
Så det blir ju som en spärrvis.
Och ju större bolaget är ju liksom, det blir ju så mycket nytt.
Rörelser ändras ju väldigt mycket på det sättet också.
Och det tycker jag också är roligt, men varje år är det som ett helt nytt sätt att jobba känner jag.
Kan du inte ta oss lite på den resan för att, från att du åkte runt i en bil och sov, ja men, du sov väl i bilen eller i...
På kontoren så, vi hade kontorssäng, vi hade säng bakom första rummet, så där sov vi.
Men från den tiden är det liksom, var du som hasslade runt där och gjorde om, ni gjorde väl om filmer till digitala...
Ja, och det gör vi fortfarande.
Och omsätter nästan 25 miljoner på årsbasis på det.
Så det är fortfarande.
Ja, det är häftigt.
Det är lite sjukt faktiskt.
Det är ingenting man tänker på att man omsätter 25 miljoner på årsbasis.
Det är ett ganska trevligt bolag.
Men från den tiden till idag när du jobbar med en stor grupp, på alla människor och man ska leda och ha koll på allting.
Hur har du genomgått några stora personlighetsförändringar?
Och skulle du säga att det finns några personlighetsdrag eller förändringar som de här behövde du verkligen förändra för att kunna leda den här sortens bolag?
Sen är det ju alltid frågan, är det för att man har blivit äldre som person eller är det för att man har blivit på lag?
Jag har hållit på med det här nu sen jag var 20.
Och självklart har man ju förändrat som person väldigt mycket på den tiden.
Det jag skulle säga är de största förändringarna är att man har blivit väldigt, väldigt, väldigt ödmjuk.
Första och främst är du anställd i ett bolag så har du ju inte alls samma kraft som du själv har.
Naturligtvis, du är anställd.
Och att vad man har för drister, eller liksom ju längre man håller på, ju mer intresserad man inte kan.
Jag använder ju LinkedIn väldigt mycket.
Jag tycker rätt så roligt med alla de här experterna inom alla områden.
Om man bara säger, ja men, aj, jag har så svårt, jag tycker ju mer jag kan, ju mindre känner jag mig säker på någonting, än om jag handlar på det sättet.
Men den största skillnaden är väl hur man är med personal och inser att min styrka handlar inte om att vara arbetsledare eller chef på det sättet.
Utan min styrka handlar om att driva försäljning.
Sen har jag en stor adress som jag jobbar med.
Men det är inte där jag skulle säga att min styrka var.
Ska jag byta jobb så är det inte något jag skulle dra till på det sättet.
Kan du inte ge mig några exempel på, det blir svårt kanske att säga utan att känna att man exkluderar någon, men under den här resan så finns det säkert vissa kompetenser du verkligen känner de har varit avgörande för att ta bolaget framåt på det här sättet.
Du har nämnt Emil här till exempel.
Men finns det några andra keypersoner, keypersonligheter eller förmågor som bara där behövs i varje stort företag liksom?
Ja, sedan är det också olika faser i olika delar av bolaget.
Det är också jätteviktigt.
Vi har en del ägare som har varit lagerchef under en lång period, som har gjort en rejält mycket under den här perioden med corona, för att faktiskt få saker att lösa sig.
Olle heter han, han jobbar inom bolaget nu också, utan hand hade vi aldrig klarat logistiken under ökningstakten.
Sedan har vi en controller, Joakim Oberg, som kommer in som ekonom och controller, som har bidragit extremt mycket till vår lönsamhet med saker som jag själv inte har hunnit med.
Det är utför att jag är inne i detaljer, han granskar alla kostnader och sådana saker.
Men det hinner man inte och han gör det mycket bättre än vad jag har gjort.
Nu på slut har vi fått in en ny logistikchef som har blivit extremt, extremt viktig för bolaget, som har logistik erfarenhet på ett sätt som vi absolut inte har känt tidigare.
Som också bidrar väldigt mycket.
Så egentligen, det finns så extremt många som har varit så viktig för resan.
För annars hade vi inte kommit dit här idag.
Jag tänker att de här personerna som har varit väldigt viktiga på det sättet, har du märkt det när du har intervjuat och tagit in dem eller har de bara steppat?
För det är väldigt svårt att hitta bra personal och det är väldigt svårt att få in den här sortens riktigt tunga aktörer som verkligen hjälper upp bolaget.
Jag är lite nyfiken på om det är någonting du har känt från start eller om de har steppat upp tre år senare och bara, det här är min värld nu.
Nej, de har varit väldigt viva från början så det är inte någonting som kommer senare utan jag har märkt från början på alla de här.
Vi kan ju säga, jag vet inte vad man ska säga, men du har ju ett plattformsbyte här idag.
Du är lite smådistra i vissa sekunder.
Det får man vara, men det måste ju vara.
Hur många plattformsbyten har du gjort under den här resan?
Det är inte plattformsbyte utan systemuppgradering som de håller på med.
Men vi har varit på samma e-handelsplattform sen vi startade.
Det är ingenting, det har varit samma sen vi började.
Kodbyran, köpte och sägla, vi har börjat till nu.
Det är sjukt, de måste verkligen ha vuxit med er.
Jag gissar att ni är deras största kund.
Ja, det är vi absolut.
Vi har haft ett jättebra samarbete under åren.
De har fått ut mycket genom oss också.
Det var inte alls det vi skulle prata om.
Men det är lite intressant för att nästan alla idag går ju på såna här kända lösningar.
Det verkar vara nästan konsensus nu att man ska gå på Shopify när man börjar e-handel.
Finns det någon fördel med att gå på lite mer obskura lösningar?
Jag menar inget illa med det utan vi ligger på en Magento-plattform.
Så jag fattar.
Finns det någon fördel med att jobba mer personligt?
Ja det är jättesvårt för mig att veta.
Jag har aldrig legat på en annan plattform på det sättet.
Absolut, alla har pratat om Magento idag.
Det känns som det som gäller om man ska börja.
Men jag tycker också att mycket där har blivit en konstig diskussion.
I alla fall är jag med i Anders rådarna på Facebook och sådana saker.
Man letar efter en billig plattform som möjligt.
Och där tycker jag så jävla underligt.
Man kan tycka att ett bekymmer om plattformen kostar 500 spänn eller 20 000 i månaden.
Om du skulle driva ett företag på heltid.
Vad skulle en butikslokal kosta?
Att man värderar inte plattformen tillräckligt mycket.
Jag gillar det tänket.
Det handlar inte bara om månadskostnaden när man startar upp, utan när man har lite volym så behöver man tänka funktioner och vad man kan skapa och liknande.
Du nämnde förut att ni går på det här med magkänsla och ni gör grejer bra för att ni har varit med länge och liknande.
Men vi har ju ganska många bolag som har haft svårigheter under den här tiden där det faktiskt är, ja men där det har varit svårt, det är lågkonjunktur och liknande.
Det jag egentligen letar efter är, vad gör ni bra jämfört med andra bolag som är i en liknande situation?
Finns det några keypointers som verkligen, ah, helvete vad bra vi är på de där grejerna?
Eller har ni bara lyckats pricka helt rätt?
Det är det jag pratade om tidigare.
Jag själv har kontroll på köp, marknadsföring och prissättning.
Istället för att det är en jättestor organisation som går åt olika håll, så har jag stenkoll på hela processen själv, och kan ta väldigt snabba beslut.
Jag tror det är en väldigt, väldigt stor styrka för oss.
Finns det en stagnationsrisk där då?
Det måste finnas någon anledning till att inte alla gör på det sättet, eller är det bara för att man inte känner att man hinner med, eller varför gör inte alla björnstylen?
Det är väl kompetens, eller om du inte kan Google Ads så ska du inte jobba med det alla.
Du måste ju vara duktig på det du gör.
Och det är ett väldigt komplexta område, jag lägger väldigt mycket av min tid bara på att hänga med i vad som händer, och att jag får rum och läser på.
Men varje vecka lägger jag flera timmar bara på att hänga med i vad som händer egentligen.
Och sen tror jag också att det är driv som är ett bekymmer i många bolag, och många säljer bolagen vidare och sådana saker så kommer det in folk som kanske inte har samma driv.
Eller man tänker för mycket att man ska jobba som ett storbolag i hela organisationen.
Vilket som för oss, vi måste göra det när det gäller logistik och de bitarna för där är det så pass stort.
Där kan man inte driva det bara på att liksom lösa pankar, utan där måste allting vara väldigt specifikt och strukturerat och sådana saker.
Det är alltså just förkälningsdelen och driva i handen.
Där kan vi jobba snabbt.
Det är snabbfotare som fan.
Det är så yrka ska jag säga.
Jag gillar det, det är lite annorlunda tänk.
Det är nästan sådana här att stanna upp och försöka ta in tankarna lite grann.
Man vill inte bara flowa på.
Det är inte så logiska svar.
Om man inte är intresserad av marknadsföring eller själva nitty gritty på marknadsföringen, finns det något annat område som folk borde gräva ner sig i mer än vad de gör när de är grundare eller vd?
Jag tror att det handlar väldigt mycket om.
Det handlar om att lägga in timmar, du jobbar ju inte extremt.
Nu lägger jag insett, jag har en väldigt bra grund i det vi gör.
Min tanke är, ifrån jag valde att lägga mig så har jag en tanke på er andra.
Hur kan vi göra det här bättre?
Vad kan vi göra bättre?
Hela tiden säger situationen, vad fan det där borde göra?
Sen är det också mycket att nätverka med andra.
Jag har varit ut mycket på konferenser och sådana saker, så jag har i stort sett nätverk med alla.
Man talas vid mig några gånger i månaden, där man utvisar erfarenheter och berättar vad man har gjort.
De bara, vad fan var smak det där ska jag göra?
Man byter ut mycket i den vägen.
Och det också.
Känner du att du har offrat saker för att bygga ditt bolag eller känner du att det har varit den?
Du säger att du har lagt väldigt mycket tid och liknande, upplever du det som en uppoffring eller mer som att det här var liksom min resa med livet?
Man har ju såklart ofta saker.
Röstom är jag inte så stort.
Men sen jag fick barn har jag dragit ner, speciellt när jag blev lite större, nu har jag dragit ner väldigt mycket jobb.
Jag var ju inte inne på kontor och reporter i veckan på sommaren.
Men jag har också lärt mig att jobba i varje sekund jag har över.
Jag har väl lagt på nästan vart jag än går.
Jag sitter under fem minuter och väntar på ett läkeförsök, men då sätter jag mig och jobbar.
Jag har den här idritten, jag fikar veten kvart.
Jag sätter mig och jobbar då.
Jag försöker utnyttja varenda sekund för att jobba när jag inte är ledig.
Så att man hela tiden kan köpa på och komma någon kvart.
Men i sommar var jag inte på kontor i veckan utan jobbade bara på tåg, bilresor och när dottern sov.
Så jag utnyttjade tiden på det sättet.
Så jag tycker inte jag offrar något på det sättet.
Ni har ju fortfarande ett gäng butiker, om jag förstår det rätt.
Det är samma, tio stycken.
Tio stycken, är det bara i Sverige?
Nio i Sverige och en i Norge.
Har ni kvar dem av mest nostalgiska skäl eller är de faktiskt bidragande till verksamheten?
Jag skulle inte säga att de bidrag är handeln på det sättet.
Vi ser att i Sverige står det bara för 17% av våra omsättningar.
Så skulle butiken vara superviktig, att e-handeln skulle gå bra, så skulle det gå ännu bättre.
De är lönsamma, det är de.
Och framförallt att vi har extremt duktig personal i våra butiker som har varit med väldigt länge.
Så skulle vi få en personalflykt som många skulle sluta i våra butiker, men då kanske vi skulle omvärdera att ha butikerna kvar.
Men så länge vi har en kärna med personal, med butiker som är superduktiga och superviktiga, så ser vi ingen anledning att vara närmare på det.
Men är de fortfarande lönsamma eller är det någonting som ni får täcka upp?
De är lönsamma, det är de.
Det är inte någon jättelönsamhet men de går inte minus.
Och de tar inte så mycket tankemöda från det kanske?
Nej.
Jag tycker bara det är intressant att man bibehåller, är det någonting som ni kommer expandera om utomlands eller är det liksom?
Inte utomlands, utan det vi kikar på eventuellt är att kanske byta de större butikslokaler i Sverige.
För det är ganska små butiker vi har runt om.
De är liksom inte anpassade till nuvarande verksamhet utan mer för överföring av film.
Så vi kikar lite på att kanske testa att byta till större butikslokaler.
Vad är nästa stora steg i Bygg-A-grupp?
Är det att fortsätta internationellt och bara ta land för land?
Eller finns det någon större förändring i Horizon?
Vi har ju haft planerna lite på att gå till USA.
Men då måste vi sätta upp en logistik där och lägga ett lag utifrån 20-30 miljoner där borta.
Annars så denna landsexpansion vi gör nu så kan vi inte expandera vidare.
Frakterna ska väta upp för mycket av marginalen.
Men vi tittar ju liksom helt enkelt.
Vi gjorde ett experiment med pryssel här i våras.
Det är Bessalja som vi har lagt ner nu.
Vi känner att vi inte kan funka.
Vi gör ju mycket satsningar för att se om det funkar eller inte funkar.
Och annars är det, den stora grejen vi ser nu är att vi har öppnat ett 3D-korslobistik i nederländerna som hoppas att vi går igång i vilken dag som helst.
Som ska skicka ut paket ut i Europa för att få ner leveranstiderna och fraktkostnaderna.
Vi kommer inte minska på lagret i Gävle men vi kommer att kunna öka fram och genom snabbare leveranser, billigare frakter, så tror vi att vi kan ta mer av den europeiska marknaden.
Så det är det stora för oss just nu skulle jag säga.
För just nu så har ni egentligen hela lagret i Gävle?
Ja, och fyra olika lager.
Eller fem olika lager sitter vi där.
Åtskilda lager, eller som ligger i Gävle?
Ja, de ligger på olika ställen i samma industrieområde.
Vi har inte plats, vi sitter på över 14 000 kvadratmeter.
Hur löser man det smidigt?
Det är inte smidigt.
Det är inte smidigt utan vi har satt upp logistikmeterna, vi har satt upp flöden för att få det att funka.
Men det är inte smidigt och det är ju personalintensivt.
Det är rätt det ska man säga.
Helvete, ja det måste vara krångligt.
Ja det är krångligt, det är det definitivt.
Och det är mycket konstiga saker, vi har satt upp sådant för att vi har ett nytt lag att öppna.
Så vi behöver komma till en gräns att vi inte kan ha ännu fler logistikdelar.
Utan då måste vi bygga upp nytt från annars.
Och det är det vi håller på med just nu.
Det är också lite intressant, hur har ni valt?
Är det så ni har vuxit lagret genom tiden att ni har köpt eller inte köpt men hyrt ett nytt, en ny lokal i anslutning till den gamla eller har ni bytt fram och tillbaka mellan olika ställen?
Vi har väl hoppat mellan.
Är det andra bytet?
Vi har gjort det bara.
Då har vi suttit på samma.
Sedan har vi fått mer ytor, sen har vi tagit fler ytor.
Det är lokalbrist i jävla, så det är svårt att hitta lokaler.
Vi får ta lite olika nödlösningar.
Just nu jobbar vi med ett externt palltäl, det står tusen pall där på palltäl i jävla.
Så vi har lite utmaningar där.
Är ni inte så pass etablerade att de bara kan bygga en lokal åt er?
Ni måste vara en ganska bra arbetsgivare där.
Funkar det inte så?
Nej, jävla kommunen är ju helt...
Sen är det väl så hur kommunlagen är.
Jävla kommunen är ju rusat.
De byggde ett industrimarkt, byggde ett nytt industrimarkt där.
Byggt gör inte så stora tomter så att det räcker för oss.
Vi ville ju bygga om en gränsvärd en kopp 20.000 m2.
Men det hade man inte anpassat tomterna för, så det skulle ta flera år innan vi skulle kunna komma mål på det.
Så nej, de skiter i oss egentligen.
Och det är så att man liksom...
Du har ju lite den här...
Jag följer dig på LinkedIn.
Du har ju en tendens att kanske inte sugarcoat allting du säger eller ha lite åsikter.
Har du fått mycket skit för dig genom åren eller?
Nej, alltså jag håller igen väldigt mycket tycker jag.
De åsikter jag går ut med, har jag inga bekymmer att stå bakom.
På det sättet.
När jag går ut med det står jag för.
Jag har inga bekymmer för det.
Nej, jag gillar det.
Jag tror att det hade behövts mer sånt i...
I företagsvärlden överlag.
Att man kallar ut saker som inte funkar.
Jag tycker det är ett...
Jag för mig att du la någon status någon gång om att de lade till fraktkostnader på något sätt och så började du täga in någon som var ansvarig på något ställe.
Jag bara gillar det sättet att jobba för att folk tvingas ta lite ansvar.
Jag gillar också att lyfta fram leverantörer.
Inte mindre bolag, de ska jag aldrig stå fram och lyssna på.
De ska man liksom inte dra i skiten.
Jag tycker det är så pinsamt med många stormedel, speditörer och allt möjligt som bara pissar på kunderna egentligen och agerar som bluffbolag.
Det drar jag väldigt gärna fram i ljuset.
Vad är sånt?
Jag kan faktiskt tycka att det är beundransvärt.
Jag tror att vi hade fått en bättre marknad om folk.
Det behöver inte alla hålla med, men om folk hade åsikter så blir det tydligare och folk tar tag i grejer snabbare.
Jag är säker på att du fick ett meddeland inom 24 timmar från någon som sa i alla fall att de skulle försöka ta tag i någonting.
Jaha, men så är det ju.
Om man nu ska sätta igång ett bolag om man vill bli stor, är det, förutom den här körbara körmentaliteten och att man faktiskt behöver satsa ordentligt, vilka egenskaper eller vad är det man behöver ta med sig in i bolaget för att man faktiskt ska kunna växa upp det?
Alltså jag tror att det är väldigt lyckat att man förstår att det kommer att ta tidig när man lyckas.
De första åren jag körde, jag hade ett annat jobb medans, som betalade min lön med mina spafengar tror jag slut.
Jag hade två anställda och kunde inte ta ut lön själv.
Och att det handlar om att lägga väldigt, väldigt mycket till var.
Man måste vara beredd på den där fotbollningen.
Jag hade inte kunnat göra den här resan när jag hade varit.
Det hade inte varit värt det.
Absolut inte.
För i min värld är det mycket tid man måste lägga för att lyckas.
Få stenkoll och liksom orka och göra det bättre än alla andra.
Oftast får man vara beredd på att det kan skitas hela tiden.
Du säger innan man lyckas, skulle du säga att du har lyckats?
Jo, men det skulle jag väl känna då.
Vi har kommit till en punkt där det går bra.
Eftertidssamt.
Jo, nej men det tycker jag väl, det tycker jag.
Absolut.
Ni har väl, det är väl bara kollegor som är delägare i ditt bolag.
Det är alltid sådana här frågor om uppköp och liknande, men vad är den stora anledningen till att du inte har tagit in kapital och på det sättet kan se ännu mer.
Om din drivkraft ändå är att se vart företaget kan ta vägen och hur stort du kan bygga det.
Varför inte ta in kapital med en aktör som hjälper dig, till exempel USA som är en jättemarknad eller?
Ska vi ta in kapital, då pappar det väldigt mycket kontrollen och har den snabbla vänligheten i bolaget.
Och att många av de större riskkapitalbolagen har en väldigt tydlig idé hur man kan bygga in det på lag.
De köper upp en befintlig verksamhet och sen ska man anpassa till det de tycker är bra.
Som också visar att det inte funkar så jävla bra i slutändan för många av dem heller.
Och att jag känner att vill jag köra det här så ska jag kunna köra och stå helt bakom tillsammans med mina kollegor som är deras lärare.
Vad vi gör.
Och att jag har inget behov av att sälja.
Jag har levt ett kostnivå för de pengar vi har kunnat ta ut på det sättet.
Så jag har liksom inget behov av att dra mig tillbaka heller.
Men om det var en liten aktör eller en stor aktör men en liten i förhållande som bara gick in och sa Björn vi bara älskar din personlighet.
Bara gör exakt vad du vill.
Här har du massa pengar.
Hade du vackert mot en sådan?
Ja, det hade jag för det kommer en demokrater och delägare på det sättet.
Nej, jag vill kunna vara på kontrollen själv.
Sedan har vi ju såklart fått genom åren, inte liksom ett konkret gerbjuden på bordet, men där man har velat titta närmare.
Då har man ju pratat om betalsmiljoner i utföljning, i sådana fall.
Och såklart har det varit lockande.
Jag ser inte att jag fyller 40 år, när jag känner mig liksom inte glad med yrkeslivet.
Och det är sant.
Och det är inte lockande att byta, säga att du skulle bli utköpt, det är inte lockande att byta bransch eller, du pratar om Härjedalen till exempel, att säga att du skulle sälja hela bolaget att bara gå all in i, nu ska jag förbättra den här kommunen eller det här området, eller göra massa satsningar på det sättet.
Nej alltså det krävs, måste jag säga, som du sa, vi kommer inte att vara ett närheten att ha ett heltidsjobb, sen var ju början här väldigt spännande.
Det är någonting jag jobbar på och lyckas med.
Så är det, definitivt.
Ja, jag köper det, jag tycker det är väldigt intressant hur man resonerar.
Vissa är så extremt inriktade på det, och du är ju väldigt egen åt andra hållet, så att säga.
Både med hur du jobbar kanske och med var du jobbar och liknande.
Nu har du ju köpt en paddelhall här och en trampolinpark ser det ut som om du startar.
Du har sagt i tidigare intervju att du är lite intresserad av träningsbranschen, att du skulle gå in i den om du fick välja.
Det är lite där.
Jag är ju i träningsbranschen.
Kommer du och jag bli konkurrenter här om fem, tio år?
Ja jag tänker om tre, fyra månader får jag nog börja passa.
Då lanserar vi tränningsprodukten helt över.
Och så har vi femtio muskler, vill vi göra priser på allt?
Nej, det är väl något jag tycker är en intressant grej.
Jag älskar ju tränning själv, cirkutränning och all form av tränning.
Det är väl liksom en hobby här, men nej det kommer nog aldrig att hända att jag gör dem.
Men du kommer att starta lite gym i Vemdalen så småningom?
Absolut, eller inte gym där utan det är en trampolinpark.
Det är inte så mycket för pensionärerna utan lite mer för folk.
Nej, för kidsen ja.
Jag får tacka dig här Björn, du ska få gå tillbaka till ditt jobb.
Jag är inte starstruck sådär, men jag har fått med mig sjukt många insikter.
Det var nog den svåraste intervjun jag har gjort.
Och jag måste väl tillägga till dig och alla jag har lyssnat, jag tycker att du är en av dem på LinkedIn idag som skriver mest intressanta inlägg, som också ger mig mycket tankiveckande saker.
Fan vad kul, vi kan sitta här och ha en liten bromance i kretskola.
Ja, exakt, exakt.
Nej men det tycker jag faktiskt, det är väldigt kul att höra dina inlägg på LinkedIn, så fortsätt med det.
Tack så mycket, vi säger tack till Björn från Big Yaw Group.
Superkul att få ha med, så ha det så bra.
Liksom som mitt hopp på RKBK, kör bara kör.
Man måste våga gasa och inte tänka efter så mycket.